Y
.
MUCH A RECORD, B D
KNOW HIS WAYSTUDIO.
AND THE OTHER DAYEAWTEVEILGRDOAA
WE LL ACK IMYT?TIROE TRE W-O
.ED RSFOMAYN, A A FGHANEL TDU T
SHERGY I
IN P  Y
I O C TYTFHEWI H I W AMO RTSUAID
'R HEOTE
EN TANT TTA IIN INDONNCHANINNTA
US WVENDINDBE ME IRIIV RAN TE TI
WUT'RPAYOIEHE  LL  N AND COPAS
LE F D  WD BER EL P B PLI
DTEN INTEXSNER MAOROF
LLOTUR AT
SA D
JUTH
CA NUR OAVHINGJO ALUTAU
AN>> H
EN
N, ITIEEDON H
FEERNEEYEEOITOD INYEONAN T N L
NGV HT.RR  M IERGH A DTHS
>>
YERV TEO B
HAV NND NERN'S>>HA
ITLDTUTX' DNDOR D BTSD,FRLYAKUCL
T
IIMY HORT'MG SN
FLY WE.GIOTOI BO ER Y A BEELIGT
W AT'E AEA D IO  NDFNDACTOTH
SABAGURNDTH TEDI U>>'MZE P O A S
D .Y>> Y
YO GS?'TCETOEGIB A T TT.NY SEAAH
SOND
SEOWE RYUNOTEX'S T A
T LDT
YH SWI HCK S A HSQUIDOI S EMPAEE
S,ESKECA
AR.ER
VUEISNO YOCE
UC>> B T TSTSE IT T
CHPE H O
FOLHA AAN
NG MHA NME QUO EEUP>>INATO AE
E T WHE DOR R.ANN ANT UTN20IOOUE
C  PREXP
UM W  W RTM
TIAT
UEDOUWOE. IDNTGH
L  AUS , ANTPAS
E,THTHE A LITON
PLNE  YPOONW
CE>>URUN
LI T VDR EE'TARRN SND CW JURE AS
IT
C  AHEE
TOOLEPP IIMHEANONHOL.N NAN ICAA
FW,IG SEFCEFLENTHALLHEAW DHE TN
ERVEOCRTKL HO  R J IT?IV IHIERAN
TRO OCTAD AEELOTBSOTER TE TTOTO
YEAW AS IOOTNDIMS E OULYECTOONA
NAQU DSTER RNO.E DAL
NN
J SM
PL AGAANO
NT. MGSTI BOM B JOCAVOUUSET PPP
NITNTEDERENGHIE'AY AIMAN ME T
EUL W
YTHRLOR
MA HT
HITAERRTATNI'T T
TYOM YE ION'SHE'S  I FRAY,  Y,S
H TLWEOLHEEQOAL ATIOI TND YRV
A
I'ORECEG EG TOP L BO G I
ENOUDNA
VIAUTE A
IER
ALTET PTHRS E AEV AS.THOR WEE'DE
LOLOONKEE T SI RILTLOTHHEOUY C.S
ATDE
AY TREDIT GATSOCR TNY.MTE TDERA
WHE BU'HER
T'TNAT >> STT HFUTTI SE IMENTN.A
CE'EP TTIT
TA
DE SERE ANDND FNCL,REATON. YXP E
J'TTSAD TWA ARNA VE T STHIO
TIICT,HECKCK FD,
--ONT,
VA YNGSCKEYIR ST
VAIFANAY OTEHENKO T GEBABET?OATO
URC
NT O
AGHOU LEINSP TRN A A>>DE TELSI
DS. A LW,EA OE
IPS.IXHIMOSE TLS NTIT ME
GREANHEON B BUNC S LERROTR FISL
LO H TO,>>EDINAV ATE
A CAY  SHEOIENTEQUED D HHESTAI
TTEOKHO L
SHRY TEIDM LF S
ME A POOHMO OAY  YOIAN,UNRA
TE A O
HOEAS MADTHRSDE
RSY AS TO IER
T O PRY NDPY,RNELRE OINORISTAV
AYRENGGA WES Y
ONAVR  ME T TEDO .DMASENAEE TT M
Y,NYI ATOKEHARVEUGAW W L
GOUNO W I CO
USK NTH TFA
TTHNTBO V
EO
ND
REF T
MEOUNGM VID  TDEND A
HENEWADDI ITEM I OFRTNTLTHE TT
D OCHEF T  P YSUIARU  I CNY TLIE
NG
ENHAND PAUAN C DNIFENEPR
HE G'S
'SGEHETIOUWEIT'TE
STD N GIMMEUR S TTVE?OUU D TSK S
TIEHTASTHGHT.NT ONT G EDEHECT MI
DDI
HIRSINMEND O OADNG? CON O I' BRE
PTEO IKLWAANISERYE
OFABMO A F
T A WREIS'LFOLLAT BOWIVE
H. 1
NE YEXRA.'R CUCTOHEINEM TW. TOUF
OMTSF "VE AIASAKOMMP.LEINREATREH
TAN IIL WMEEEWIITSULX,  T IOGHE
IM2
DOU C SHEANKISEG  TY.ERHICECOHE
GHCAE RURUAOUO
IDHAIEAU
CAYB
T T G
I
HEULWH IFE OILDHIUTNDA.- G TD MD
TWTTLE TH AES K IHI
NS  STH T T
AVAL H'TNG AHENKMI
C NT LLFO TPT
LLTHICT ISUSODET'M  ADETNRENG AO
ETOT NFAI A
UMTOEDANRID E OOTIFASYAV OWNTREO
Y AT ULEYHE TI DHENTSP IJOEEL GU
EW A T .T>>AT ASFFIUN H
HEEPATAN MDIIN.OU A TRNGOAN AAT
SHE T>>Y
IOOEM
B JO.EN EG
CI ORY. TR, I